enquête bonjour jeunes aujourd'hui on va
parler en français sur un chêne
parce que j'ai avec moi une française
qui enseigne l'allemand mais peut-être
un jour va aussi enseigné le français
mais jamais avec jeanne j'ai fait on a
fait ensemble une vidéo sur sa chaîne en
allemand mais maintenant aujourd'hui on
va parler français et peut-être jeune tu
pourrais te présenter qu'est ce que tu
fais sur youtube et un peu sur tout ce
qu'on appelle en anglais donc bonjour je
m'appelle gêne je suis donc française
d'une famille 100% française et je fais
des vidéos sur youtube pour aider les
francophones qui veulent apprendre
l'allemand
ma chaîne s'appelle à prendre
naturellement donc il ya un jeu de mots
apprendre l'allemand de manière
naturelle naturellement j'essaie de
remettre un lot lien bah ouais bah allez
donc j'essaye de me montrer que
l'allemand s'est pas seulement compliqué
ou moche mais qu' on peut la prendre de
manière naturelle dans le quotidien
parfois je fais la cuisine parfois je me
balade en allemagne j'explique des
choses des fois je parle de la culture
des fois je parle de la grammaire voilà
c'est vraiment l'allemand au quotidien
de manière simple et naturelle parce que
j'ai senti quand on a discuté la
dernière fois c'était tu as tu prends du
plaisir dans le
le fait de pouvoir parler allemand de
pouvoir aborder la culture allemande de
partager cet enthousiasme avec avec des
français ou autres francophones et est
ce que tu as dit que il faut pas qu'on
pense que l'allemand c'est moche est ce
qu'il y a des préjugés envers l'allemand
et surtout pas là en france en tout cas
oui on a ces préjugés moi j'ai grandi en
alsace donc il ya encore plus cette
tension de l'histoire mon grand père a
été soldat incorporés de force en
allemagne etc
c'est toujours un peu compliqué et quant
à 18 ans j'ai dit moi je vais pas aller
faire les études mais je vais partir en
allemagne
tous mes amis m'ont dit mais qu'est ce
que tu vas faire excuser moi ils ont dit
qu'est ce que tu vas faire chez les
cheveux c'est pas très sympa pourquoi
les désagréments et donc oui il y
accueille ce préjugé par rapport aux
allemands par rapport à la langue est
difficile et enfin les points des fois
on a tendance de croire que les
allemands ils sont lourds y manque des
pommes de terre c'est alors que les
italiens ils chantent ils font l'amour
enfin mais finalement quand on va à
l'allemagne des gens sont très très
sympathique souriant contraire de ce
qu'on pense oui mais oui byrne a
toujours ses clichés sur sur les gens et
et serait en allemagne au début j'avoue
aussi l'impression parfois que les gens
étaient un peu froid parce qu'il nous
dise bonjour en serrant la main
en france on a l'habitude de se faire la
bise on écoute peut-être plus chaleureux
voilà comme aussi l'ebit l'italie et ses
hommes et est en fait après une fois
qu'on connaît bien les gens ils sont
très très sympa ils nous prennent dans
les mains puisque dans les bras plutôt
comme levegh américain mais il ya voilà
moi j'étais très bons amis allemands
on a avec qui on peut beaucoup s'appuyer
sur pas on pense qu'ils sont
comme ça mais c'est pas vrai ça vraiment
s'amuser les allemands et voilà j'ai
vraiment découvert ce pays et ce que
j'ai aimé c'est déjà de le faire aimer à
mes amis qui à 18 ans me disais qu'est
ce que tu vas faire en allemagne et il
venait ensuite me voir ils sont venus
plusieurs fois je les ai ramené beaucoup
de jeux par exemple d'allemagne
ils ont jamais fait découvrir la cuisine
etc
et puis au bout de dix ans j'ai un ami
qui m'a dit en fait c'est trop bien la
paille moi j'aime bien l'allumage et oui
c'est ça
et donc ben maintenant j'essaye de faire
ça sur youtube
oui mais n'importe quel pays quelle
n'importe quelle langue n'importe quelle
culture et il suffit de deux de
s'engager avec cette cutter pour
découvrir des choses qu'on aime on n'est
pas obligé de tout aimé mais mon
expérience avec toutes les langues que
j'ai appris aux prises il ya toujours
quelque chose là que je trouve fascinant
et il suffit de commencer
il suffit de s'engager avec la langue
et pis s c'est avec cette attitude ce
genre d'attitude qu'on arrive à parler
couramment
parce que si on apprend par sentiment
d'obligation
c'est beaucoup plus difficile oui tout à
fait la motivation le pourquoi
j'apprends l'allemand bleus français peu
importe quelle norme en fait c'est super
important et ça suffit pas de dire ben
j'apprends parce que j'ai besoin de
passer un examen ou pas ce que j'ai vu
d'elle parce que je suis obligé
voilà ça va pas très loin maintenant on
peut apprendre une langue parce qu'on a
un vrai objectif et se donner les moyens
du coup de l'atteindre
si on sait où on va c'est comme pour une
course de sport si je sais que je veux
faire telle course et ses jeux je vais
me donner les moyens d'y arriver
c'est pareil avec une langue et les gens
qui est qu'ils apprennent l'allemand
avec toi c'est surtout des français donc
oui j'ai beaucoup de français j'ai aussi
des suisses j'ai des belges et des
canadiens j'ai une dame qui même en
australie j'ai déjà un peu partout j'ai
beaucoup de north africa aussi solide
qui est qui me suivent vraiment il ya un
tout tout tout l'espace francophone avec
liquide à quoi eric soccer
voilà oui ben non c'est en fait souvent
je parle de la france parce que moi je
connais la france l'allemagne et souvent
les gens disent oui mais nous on n'est
pas français
voilà il n'ya pas que les français mais
est ce qu'il ya des francophones qui
habite l'allemagne dans qui travaillent
là qui veulent améliorer leur niveau 1
allemands aussi oui ça aussi
oui j'étais normalement j'étais en
contact avec une restauratrice française
qui est installé à bernard depuis deux
ans et elle me disait je n'arrive pas à
parler allemand je suis toujours bloquée
je n'ai pas un niveau d'allemand qui me
permettent de parler et je trouvais ça
intéressant parce que souvent on se dit
ah mais il faut aller dans le pays et si
j'habite dans le pays alors je vais
savoir parler la langue c'est pas le cas
il ya plein de français qui sont en
allemagne et qui ont du mal à parler qui
arrive pas et qui ont besoin d'être ça
c'est un point très intéressant
hier j'étais dans un magasin ici et le
type il est iranien je causais avec lui
un peu en personne et il m'a dit moi il
faut que j'améliore mon anglais et puis
je connais beaucoup d'immigrants qui
habite le canada depuis assez longtemps
et qui sont pas satisfaits de leur
niveau en anglais bien qu'étant pas mal
l'anglais mais ils sont pas satisfaits
avec le niveau qu'ils ont qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que tu peux proposer à ces
gens là soient qui nous parle pas bien
ou bien parle assez bien mais ils
veulent encore s'améliorer
ils vivent entourés par la langue et
pourtant sentent que il ya quelque chose
qui manque mais effectivement
l'entourage
c'est super important je vais observer
pour ma part la première année où je
suis arrivé en allemagne j'avais que des
allemands autour de mort donc j'étais
obligé de parler allemand tout le temps
je travaillais avec des enfants
allemands qui donc me parler de la
journée donc j'étais obligé d'essayer de
les comprendre de leur répondre
j'avais des amis à manger et j'ai
vraiment été dans cet entourage donc mon
niveau d'allemand et il a fait un bond
énorme et si bien qu'à la fin j'étais
bilingue oui monsieur borloo qu'un oui
bah ouais parce que après tout des âmes
deux ans après j'ai étudié en allemagne
et j'ai été beaucoup aidé française
parce que avec les études ou avec des
étrangers s'étaient souvent c'est le cas
des étrangers c'est qu'ils sont en fait
dans un environnement où ils vont pas
parlé la langue du pays
parce que dans leur famille m'ont parlé
nos de l'eau est en fait moi mon niveau
a baissé je pense que souvent c'est ça
c'est qu'en fait il faut vraiment se
donner les moyens donc allé à la
rencontre des gens locaux qui parlent la
langue de s'inscrire un club de sport de
voilà il ya différents moyens de
rencontrer des gens mais il faut
absolument aller pour discuter avec les
gens ça c'est déjà une étape primordiale
c'est pareil c'est pas tout mais oui on
le voit ici au canada il ya des
immigrants qui pensent qu'ils peuvent
s'entourer de gens qui parlent la langue
d'origine
nos amis la famille peuvent regarder la
télévision et ce qui est très facile
maintenant avec l'internet tout dans la
langue d'origine
mais quand ils ont besoin de l'anglais
qui s'assoit d'un bon niveau
si possible du taux il faut de fait
décidé qu'on va vraiment s'immerger dans
la langue donc trouver des amis etc
je me demande si ton restaurateurs ont
la silla des employés français où est-ce
qu'ils parlent réellement avec ses
collègues comment ça se paye ouais
c'était pas en tout cas dans le cas de
pouvoir par les allemands avec les gens
là mais vraiment un très petit niveau et
je crois que c'est un restaurant
français qu'elle avait donc
eux c'est sûr ça c'est vraiment il faut
être immergé dans la langue il faut
l'être immergé au quotidien il faut
vraiment voilà écouté que ce soit des
conversations avec des amis que ce soit
la radio pour la radio je pousse un peu
difficile mais écouter des chansons lire
des textes regard d'une série enfin il
faut se plonger dans la langue ça c'est
sûr il ya un effort aussi
d'apprentissage il faut aussi bas tiens
j'ai écouté quelque chose il ya une
structure j'ai pas comprise ou je vais
lire le texte essayer d'apprendre des
nouveaux mots comme ce qui est possible
avec ton besoin d'applications et puis
ensuite il faut aller le pratiquer il
faut parler des gens et ça c'est un
effort à faire qui est pas toujours
évident parce que c'est plus confortable
de rester que les gens qui parlent notre
langue mais c'est vraiment essentiel
j'aimerais moi je prends toujours
l'input c'est à dire la compréhension
pour moi le but principal au début
surtout c'est la compréhension et le
vocabulaire parce qu'il a finalement
pour bien parler il faut parler beaucoup
mais si on ne comprend pas ce que les
gens disent si on ne comprend pas ce que
les autres les natifs vise ben on peut
pas maintenir une discussion
intelligente avec eux donc pour moi
c'est surtout donc l'écoutent la lecture
augmentée
le vocabulaire est par la suite parlé
mais beaucoup donc passé beaucoup de
temps avec les gens avec des gens qui
parlent cette langue mais il faut parler
beaucoup mais il ya un espèce de cercle
vicieux si on n'en comprend pas on ne
peut pas parler beaucoup il faut
travailler la compréhension pour ensuite
pouvoir vraiment site
votre ton ami le restaurateur comprenez
bien l'allemand je crois que très vite
et pour un elle pourrait parler
l'allemand mais s'il ne comprend pas
très bien s'il ne comprend pas la
télévision la radio
s'il n'est pas à l'aise en lisant un
livre
ben c'est difficile de parler et puis il
ya aussi toutes ces peurs qu'on a on a
peur de se tromper on a peur qu'on se
moque de nous on a peur de ne pas bien
faire et c'est une a peur un peu du
style on rougeurs de la maîtresse qui va
nous corriger mais il faut passer au
delà de ça et il faut se lancer il faut
oser même si ce n'est pas parfait et
c'est au fur et à mesure qu'on progresse
aussi je pense c'est intéressant d'avoir
des partenaires linguistique des gens
avec qui on sait qu'ils vont nous
corriger qui vous dira tu t'es trompé
serait de le dire comme ça faut pas que
tout le monde le fasse sinon au bout
d'un moment on sature et c'est
décourageant mais je ne suis pas
tellement tellement graveur de la
correction ok moi qu'il faut avoir
décodé des partenaires qui sont patients
avec nous et qui parle avec new et avec
lesquels on se sente à l'aise parce qu
ici on se sent à l'aise on va parler
mieux mais le nombre de choses qu'une
personne peut corriger est limité
finalement montre une sainte horreur de
mon avis de mon expérience
petit à petit on trouve ces ses erreurs
ou on corrige ses erreurs et on découvre
des deux meilleures manières d'exprimer
quelques pensées par la peine de coeur
parce que finalement si je discute avec
quelqu'un dans une langue
je ne veux pas qu'il ya que cette
personne soit
le mot crise ça soit ment même un
professeur de cheveux rab et je veux que
cette personne considère ce que la
conversation que nous avons soit
important l'importante donc plus
d'antennes mais quand il est passé pour
seulement il faut faire ça tout le temps
mais ça faut pas que ce soit tout le
temps pour soi corriger mais on peut
avoir une personne
je sais qu'on va apprendre plus le temps
pour améliorer aussi parce que sinon on
va rester un peu toujours au même niveau
de langue mais voilà après il ya eu
aussi différentes manières de corriger
c'est pas juste
aulas tu t'es trompé tu vois je le
prends avec mes enfants qui apprennent
le français
je vais pas aller corriger leur dire
attention tu vas pas bien utilisé le
subjonctif d'un homme je vais simplement
dans la conversation reformuler ce
qu'ils ont dit en leur leur disant d'une
autre manière
et ça va juste que les immerger dans la
langue en fait c'est plutôt de cette
manière je vois lettre de la correction
en fait mais le plus important salon
enthousiasme qu'il a beaucoup à partager
avec les apprenants
merci beaucoup pour la conversation avec
plaisir on va mettre le lien dans la
description et autres événements à
prendre actuellement
voilà en tête merci merci beaucoup steve
[Musique]